die jungs jetzt schauen wir mal ob hier
die curry am arbeiten in svenja arbeiten
ist ja ist sie die größte jupiter
verschwendung die simons gehabt ich
mache jemand hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen blase keine freunde
speed mehr ich brauche diesen einsamen
zusammen mit gewinnt sagt und der
weniger ist gerade im livestream und
filter den krater und das sieht schon
sehr geil aus nein oh nein wie süß die
broncos haben sind so süß die haben den
docking domain long verbots der habe ich
fast vergessen was an die macht
wir haben den doktor vollständig für
mich nein nein das ist eine idee
schwirrte und voll die niedlichen heute
keinen arsch poppen toppen
ob in den arsch [ __ ] stars ein harter
brocken so gucken weil die stadt an
ja wie man hier sieht es hier ein dicker
klops zehn gesetzt worden um alles
wieder aufzufüllen
da strahlen was ist was machen die so
ich muss jetzt erst mal weißt du kennst
du dich mit einer quali aus also ich
konnte eure kommentare jetzt auch noch
nicht lesen leute erstmal farmville
lokhalle natürlich gefahren
coole leute wollen ganz recht farben
gehen er sich noch vom main aus des
nutzers aus recht junge weniger den
leistungen gesagt dass die der extra so
dings reinpacken sollen so ihr spaß
meist sowie wie toll brocken fans war
die am altrhein gemacht voll geil was
wäre box mich da
jetzt natürlich die frage ob und wann
und wo ist das loch versteht ihr zum
beispiel kisten mit dem you met ich kann
es nicht genau festmachen ob das jetzt
komisch kisten sind oder tatsächlich ob
es zum kader gehört wisst ihr das ist
wirklich für mich schwieriger du klaust
das doch jetzt nicht nein nein ich klar
dass nicht du glaubst dass du bist dann
verfügt einiger eltern in den
verschickten ego engagiert gute laune
als ob du das jetzt einfach abziehen des
ähnlich im urlaub rom sei bereit alles
you better gehört mir könnt mich alle am
arsch lecken luca was ja okay was ich
mache
max willst du 24
draußen was ich denn hier ich muss
irgendwas hier lassen
okay ich hab ganz erklären ich habe
jetzt ein bereich ich hab das jetzt mal
bist du
das heißt ich hätte wohl was geht ab du
vergibt als ich nach graz schon ich habe
meine curry verloren nein kann manchmal
nach oben la jetzt habe ich es gepackt
es regnet kaugummis scheiße ist patrick
addai mit einem loch das ist hier wie
eine schwule maschine
früher hast du mal erkannt zu haben wir
müssen gleich alle mappen ribéry muss
ich arbeiten gehen scheiße ich werde
dann hakt das hier wissen gar nicht eine
soul ab alles klar
halt die schnauze ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich einen orientieren was kann nicht
glauben was nicht was gehört mir erhalte
eine schnauze regelt das ist alles voll
schwierig für mich hier lukas euch
machen wie du bist so einiger wenn so
ein mächtiger schwarzwald technik und
sowas habe ich auch gemacht habe ich
jetzt auch langsam ich habe jetzt genug
materialien henry viii bitte erstmal zum
haus hin kommen immer dann live ich
würde aber gern die nacht durchmachen
ich habe so viel energie
lukas mit gerlos nicht den negativen ich
freue mich wenn ich zu meinem haus sehen
g und jede sich zeigen müssen stimmen
aus dem boden ragen ich finde so witzig
den hat nix mehr regiert ist aber über
mich lustig wird aber der landesliste
jupiter den hat immer noch mehr als du
ich habe schon wieder pimmel of my soul
ab endlich könnt ja hat glaube ich nicht
mal mehr hat mehr als ich oder ich habe
jetzt einfach die komplette kiste you
metal jetzt gibst anfressen das ist mein
wässerchen trinken eine so jungs jetzt
schauen wir mal ob tier die query am
arbeiten ist wenn ihre arbeiten ist ja
ist sie die größte you meter
verschwendung dieser ausgabe ich mache
dem weg jemand als elementar steinigt
mich alle passt aber die seals langsam
in den
auch 98 jemand nicht will in diamant
kiste machen
ich weiß es lohnt sich aber guck mal
mama ich hab guck doch mal bitte
übrigens luca ja ich hab's nicht
geklappt weißt warum als die man mir
nämlich erlaubt hat das herauszunehmen
als ob das was in der kiste was in der
produktions kiste ist das was in der
kiste produziert also in der kiste in
dem es trabi kälter nee was aus der
kiste rauskommt auf das was ich meine
nicht in den anderen kiste da was
wirklich sehr in der produktion skills
der wirkliche output seo metern ja ich
habe junge das ist geil und ich habe ich
dann darf ich das doch bestimmt auch mal
ähnlich hatte darfst das nicht du musst
dir persönlich fragen sonst wirst du
gefängnis und dann und lena hat die
halbe stadt in die luft gesprengt muss
nicht ins gefängnis
lena ist aber auch was anderes weil da
ist cool okay das war's dann von dieser
frau ich musste erst mal dran bauen
liebt deine tochter so viele goldene
peitsche habt kann ich das locker bis zu
mir nach oben
ich musste erst mal eine goldkette draus
machen glaube ich muss man dem noch zwei
weg geh doch mal das goldtrikot meter
guck mal ich mach es einfach alles aus
ju meter was wollt ihr machen kuck mal
wer ist der biber aber du hast keinen
plan ich habe mir bewusst einfach juli
meter juli messen und trotzdem wählt der
liga waren 56 oder sechster
ich habe 900 ungefähr weil es kann du
vergeht wallis kann und jetzt bringe ich
die goldene peitsche
nun habt ihr gehört der joker bringt
goldpreis hoch und die md führen jetzt
führend zu sams gefängnis meinen gästen
du bist
und wir haben jetzt hier schon mal
leisen kiste ich habe ja noch mehr juni
wohin damit wohin damit
ich habe auch ganz viel tierleid denn da
nicht auf eine nummer 1 lukas viel
cleverer ist achter generiert immer noch
diese scheiß muster junge ist der
langsam lukas euch allen ich habe hier
sechs verfickte solarpanels dran und er
ist unfassbar langsam machen es auch
erstmal ganz vieles solarpanels und dann
werde ich erst mal schön dick m g
kräften aber dann müsst ihr ein bisschen
helfen leute denn ihr müsst mir sagen
wie das am besten mit kabels verbinde
arrangieren und so dass es am
effektivsten ist
ich wollte mal was sagen luca nicht luca
schau mal alle leute megaprojekt sind
produktiv außerdem haben sie nicht und
wir sind einfach die coolsten bei dem
auch noch der kunst aber jetzt bin ich
auch produktiv mal wieder zurück auf old
school basis wir uns doch eigentlich
einfach nur ne portal gun legen dann bin
ich der könig hier komme ich mache gar
nicht erreicht trotzdem was ja du
erreichst gar nichts das erreichen
natürlich erreiche ich was ich denn ich
habe ja meter ich habe 2 soll ab ende
haben jetpack ich machen reckels ohne
helm ich hätte diesen folgen richtig
viel vor ich werde euch mit dem
geliebten cf sprayer werde ich noch mal
ein bisschen die stadt verbieten ihren
ich habe zwar noch keine kommentare
ausgewertet wer jetzt genau das nächste
opfer meines beton kriegs werden soll
aber ich habe mir das schon paar nette
leute ausgesucht die optisch beton
fressen wenn du möchtest kannst du gerne
in meinen beton sklave sein
man hat einen staatsgast was überhaupt
mit beton beton
das ist so eine lustige sache da springe
ich wie geht denn wie krieg ich denn die
diamant gecastet alter hat sich kraft
jetzt mal leute ich hab ja tausend mal
gesagt ich werde mich darum kümmern dass
ich ein radio basteln werde scheiße ich
hab jetzt geht
kopper cable und die party vor allem ich
habe auch so viele you better junge wenn
jetzt nicht an gott sich verantwortlich
wer was wo wie viel redest du hallo
kumpel kann da nicht kommen das ist
schade
dann ist der ganze spuk dann muss ich
für die ganze zeit aufnehmen
also sei schade für die leute die mögen
doch deine videos gar nicht das echt
kacke ja ich werde jetzt immer 30
minuten voll machen damit das bei mir
auch produktiv auch sie genau und ich
mache immer fünf minuten folgen damit
dass bei ihm aussieht wird er richtig
viel hochladen richtig dann mache ich
nämlich einen lauf ihr wisst schon wenn
ich meine so und jetzt hier kämpften
kernkraft meine freunde es geht immer
weiter ab macht sein
aufgrund der let go viel hoch aber ich
werde gering einholen
ich werde auch ein leistung macht ein 47
jahre lang teams kommen an das schon mal
gut
nicht nur ihr wie gar nicht das leben
aber so viel scheiß halter ich bin so
kaputt im gehirn aber so viel ich habe
so viel aufgenommen herbst gamescom
video aufgenommen alles gamescom
ja ich habe für das für die gamescom
sowie gemacht war nicht darum laufen
weil die leute nicht bloß nicht
ansprechen sollen ohne witz verloren
es gibt herr über die schellen teil nein
so schlimm löcher war ich möchte auch
ein paar tage ruhe haben
aber ich glaube mich da ich glaube dass
lukas wird das mir so viel leute
ansprechen daher jolo swex weg so jetzt
haben die diamant kiste jemand ist es
nur für junge mütter gedacht nur guck
mal leute die mich schon früh mit
limette oder um es ja noch mehr junge
mutter natur mit alle wertvollen sachen
rein okay ich habe so einen lagerraum
gebaut aber das ist erstmal egal
man hätte statt redest am fließenden
band ich mache jetzt eine mit der man im
theater auf der höhe 16 glaube ich hat
mich ein bisschen gekränkt aber ich hab
schon wieder verbunden auf jeden fall f3
höhe welche musik man
44 bin ich dann ist das einfach in das
loch ein
und damit meinen körper für 16 weiter
graben
wahrscheinlich läuft irgendwann mörder
und jemandem finden
ein bisschen pech weil hier läuft luca
sowie 13 tellereisen ein viertel völlig
power ich reisen nuggets ihr euch noch
einen single loca erzählen was machst du
damit die leute mal wissen eine art
örtchen wartet
ich brauche aber zählt so was ich mache
ich habe meinen kredit zum laufen
gebracht die läuft grad und auf
hochtouren die befördert meine ganzen
items hin
dann werde ich mir gleich diamond eyes
machen damit die alten sortieren kann
und zum beispiel die ganze scheiße wie
zum beispiel hier gravel dort und was
alles dass ich das rausschmeißen kann
und die ganzen anderen wertvollen erst
sonst in eine andere kiste sortiere
schon so gut sortieranlage krass wenn
mir alles viel zu aufwändig viel zu
aufwendig und was wollte ich jetzt mache
ich weil ich vergesse das immer so
zwischen machen jugend alzheimer - das
nicht diese zeit blut - ja ich
vielleicht fange ich hab sogar wenn ich
im garten kann ja theoretisch jetzt
schon anfangen mit zaubern ach ich hab
gar keinen waldner gut dann geht es
willst sauber ja ich bin auch ich will
auch also ich hab auch mal überlegt
zaubern aber irgendwie das haben auch
schon wieder alle gemacht weiß nun
halten schnauzte du bist so ein feines
stück scheiße ich will wirklich richtig
traurig war richtig faul
ich möchte eigentlich möchte ich einfach
keine kommentare hat sich immer wieder
gerne raus und wir haben so geredet
wenig warm ein wenig so der dritten
folge und wieso ich will da sind da sind
das erreiche nicht nur so ganz trocken
ich bin jetpack mehr wollte ich gar
nicht wollten ein jetpack haben mehr
brauche ich nicht bin ziemlich ziemlich
einfach menschlich ich brauche das
eigentlich alles auch nicht aber ich
mache das nur weil die leute das
gefordert haben und da sag ich jetzt mal
eine gute wahl sein ziemlich
unproduktives ergebnis dazu sagen
zeichnet kim jong un sicherheitsrats
rechnet schild griff lava floss mit dir
was trinkst ein schönes wasser von war
der motor ein kleines problem
das können wir nur mit julia meter lösen
ich hab das einfach so günstig ich halte
von simon ich wollte was sollte ich denn
machen ach ja ich wollte die lava zelt
zu holen
selbst damit ich die meine tunnel mining
heute machen kann und damit der reifen
kann und dass ich damit machen kann
auf der höhe wurde dann hoffentlich
macht es keinen spaß mehr macht schon
spaß weil ich merke dass ich vorankomme
obwohl ich nichts mache viel hast du
schon medium voltage solarpanels
2000/2001 tepco jeder soll ein tunnel in
die länge 2008 er macht es jetzt drei
breit das so dann packe ich da jetzt
noch eine hier in cheste dran ihr
schmeißt erstmal meine ganzen scheiß was
kann man mit millimeter was kann man aus
costa machen
ich muss mal ganz zu unterbrechen meine
ältere warte mal ganz kurz
der ist weg ich bin da höhe
nein also dass keine kommission aus drei
metern machen ich schaue einfach mal im
internet
was kann ich mir die männer aus kobe
store machen aus holz ton was willst du
denn mit unitymedia aus cobbelsdorf
machen
ach so man muss juli meter nur in die
nassen wetter einem rezept anordnen du
kannst was du meinst der mini um stein
damit kannst du was machen
ja ja ja gut stand gar nicht was denn
zwei flint und was kannst du musst immer
weiter denken sind ja gut ich war damals
erst mal ganz viel flint erwachte mal
wenn du es machen kann natürlich jetzt
für eine rasche übrigens sagt immer
bitte was ich mit diesem schönen stück
sie hinter meinem grundstück machen soll
durchaus über zu machen oder soll ich da
vielleicht irgendwie naturschutz
deutschland staatsanwaltschaft stand
schnapsladens vom klima her macht von
renz forma hermachen schnix entspannten
ein wasser mal befördert feldstein
schnauzer von kameraden sind von morgen
komme gar nix ok aus flint mache ich mir
dann dem ausleben mache ich mir dann
gleich weiter also außerdem mache ich
mir leben blöcke aus den blöcken
anreisen raus dann mache ich das ganz
viel eisen gold
siehst du
es geht schon irgendwie auch ausreisen
kann am ende april machen
später kannst du aufgebrochen
da luca was denn mit unserer kleinen
musikalischen einlage die wir hier noch
durchführen wollten ach die ja doch
gleich noch in die tat umsetzen oder du
wir nehmen ja noch wieder gehen wir denn
noch aufnehmen er noch 45 minuten auf
dann mach ich jetzt erstmal hier mit
ganz viel aus com ein kombi san luca
hast du ja hab ich da hab ich echt
benutzen kommen ja keinen bock neigen zu
machen man ich habe meinen letzten mal
kaputt gemacht aus versehen
kommt da gast einen kaputt gemacht
außerdem behindert haben irgendwie schon
schlimmsten nicht gelitten so ich mache
mir erstmal ganz wichtigen trends wie
geht es aus kupfer jungen ich kann eine
elektrische geben von mir da hast du gar
keine chance ist irgendwas kaputt geht
echt dann komme ich mal zu sich rüber
gepflegt aber dann bitte wieder auf ach
so ich dachte auf die behalten
ich brauche ich brauche selber auch eine
dann noch das alleine gehe ich halt die
kultur pur
ich würde mal sagen es geht irgendwie so
das wollte ich nicht noch mal machen
ganze grab denn ranch einen ganzen kübel
da vorne rein tun france gefahren
die mache ich den bronze ach da habe ich
schon was du brauchst du doch habe ich
echt jung als ob du kein bronze hastig
hat man die branche gemacht
bronze ist ein erstes sowie eine branche
kann man nicht als erstes wird aus
irgendwas hergestellt
dann habe ich noch nichts 12 46 fragen
wen liebt einfach riesig freuen
ja ich mache das nicht selber sicher
sicher wie nie
hast du sechs wird er bestimmt der gute
mann haben so ich habe jetzt so viel
komik du kannst du mir stellen ich hab
da kann ich daraus kein branche machen
ja klar dass jupiter kannst was alles
machen nicht ich habe meine liste nicht
alles passt eine liste ich glaube die
liste hier vor mir und da kann ich nicht
alles daraus machen
also brauchen sicher sie zum beispiel
nicht wenig so habe ich dann mein lienz
auch nicht mehr soviel bildet ich habe
10 fps welche wegen rausgehe älteres
kraft mit opti fein jungs so ich hab 64
offenen sohnes noch mehr co2 ist extrem
die jungs jungs und ladies in den
building 36 flint 46 flint weil ihr
läuft ich merke schon 56 flint soll es
nämlich mir noch mehr computer und ich
habe glaube ich nachher locker weiß
nicht 8 ex freund war es übertreibt und
nicht direkt nicht direkt übertragen
damit nicht direkt nur so ein bisschen
ok und wartet noch ein bisschen okay
dann ist es okay
das von der firma heißt das okay ich
merke dann auch irgendwie dass das böse
dem loch der arbeiten dauern hallo txtr
wenig kanal schreibt in die kommentare
wenn du bist ein süßer ich will hier
wird das gleiche geben bei mir aus
schreibt bei conny auch er sein süßes
schreibt du bist ein ganz süßer mit
vielen herzchen da freut er sich wenn
ihr das macht dann leichter borgloh
hatte gehört und geht jetzt alle zur wii
und schreibt es so will ich das und
block eurem oder auf facebook
okay ich hab jetzt flint ich das
hinterraum dann kriege ich
generell zu dem einst der klemme
zwar ist erleben zweieinhalb stack leben
habe ich jetzt
der weg ist um ständig wiederholt panel
so und dann hätte man ihm mache ich
jetzt leben blöcke oder so viele
batterien im voraus gemacht habe habe
ich auch damals 38 leben blöcke da was
mache ich jetzt eisen chillig
herausbekommen
dann schauen wir mal ganz kurz weiter
das hatte ich so nicht gelohnt ich habe
aus den ganzen text okay das lohnt
cobblestone die ich hatte eine ganze
eisen kiste voller witz eine doppel
kiste holt 91 rausbekommen 9
das heißt ein gold das hat sich nicht
gelohnt ich mache mir da jetzt einfach
zwei appellen komplette nächste
kommission und mein mini umstadt fasste
marsch das war definitiv die düstere
genommen habe mit abstand aber sie war
sehr okay das ding verbraucht sich also
ordnung
ach jetzt habe ich 16 länder perl
natürlich ich weiß nicht warum aber ich
hab' 16
so was ich übrigens noch machen das so
weiß nach das ok das nicht auf so
bekomme ich mir das mit dem ak web hebel
nicht angucken acht so stimmt brauchen
bücherregal brauchst du nicht wusste
dass ich erst mit diesem thema nur um
irgendwie was da klären firma mäßig
nenne ich weiß schon wie das geht weil
es gibt einen trick
deutschland spielt denn jetzt geradeaus
und ich weiß nicht ob das bridge ist
aber hast du bücher für mich ich habe
hier ein bisschen bahn muss bei mir
durch habe ich selber noch keine
denn dann gehen ein bisschen vielleicht
noch verlieren soll
ja ich hab ja ich hab selbst hab ich ja
dann geht noch weg
ich werde ein motorboot manchmal selber
vor ein bisschen bot alter.de cool wäre
das bitte hettstedt as rom 1 der junge
ich brauche ein goldener geht ja in gold
nugget nochmal wer solche rezept sein
rezept für zwei gold aber das lohnt sich
wirklich ist kann es einfach machen und
machen nicht langfristige des vereins wo
haben wir den grund gold gold wie so ein
kreuz an orten also vier stück
hast du musst dann geklappt haben 15 ja
ich kann da willst du weißt ich lese
rechtschreibschwäche das rechtfertigen
alles sind ärzte wenig stream scheint
vorbei zu sein
wenig wm scheint anzufangen jetzt habe
ich naja ich hab viel gold jetzt auch
ein gold sind neun goldnuggets alter
krass das weiß doch das wusste das was
ihre vor normale minecraft oder vergibt
lokal denkt überhaupt mit in deinem
gehirn
jetzt fange ich schon wieder an zu
zaubern obwohl ich das eigentlich gar
nicht soll ich habe ganz viele charts
sind paar schweiz habe ich auch dir
geben könnte so unter noch einen stick
einen zauberstab loswerden zauberstab
werten zauberstab der schenken revers
schenkel die wäsche getauscht so jung
sind zeigt was ich machen wollte
ich weiß ja was hier überhaupt
funktioniert so what does not have
charged ach so ich muss warten bis der
550 hat glaube ich die jungs dann warten
erst mal eben hat man braucht nämlich 50
wissen dafür dass man mit kopf
40 wartet eigentlich hier die krimi
schreibt damals in die kommentare ob ihr
das dieser arbeitete ich mir du hast
dich bezahlt dies ausgewandert
ernsthaft wiese ist die aus da gibt es
ärger im hause kräfte so es funktioniert
doch alles hell diese sind die
solarpanels aus dem regen
altersabhängigen bitte ihm er ist arg
versucht dem schloss geschlafen geht
dann das geht nicht
nehmen wir das jetzt scheiße so richtig
- ja weil ich sehe den regen ja nicht
welche den opti festgestellt habe das
ist noch mal - na egal jetzt kann ich
jungs schaut mal ich habe ein buch ein
zauberbuch jetzt fangen wir eben wieder
zaubern an obwohl ich das eigentlich gar
nicht wollte weil ich damit noch
abwarten wollte ich wollte so gesprochen
ich brauche ein amboss dafür stimmt der
glasfabrik aber das brauche ich auch ich
bin anders auf englisch haye will nsn
terroristin m bis 1 gegeben
im kopfstand auf seinen kopf schon alles
klar bei uns klar bei uns und haben wir
schon vier stück ich brauch insgesamt
acht ist so jung sehr zusammen schaut
man hier
es sollen table bauen
rambos mehr einfach nur table und luca
muss aber zu ganz simpel und ich einfach
mal ein amboss egal ist ob zwei jungs
läuft bei uns läuft bei uns egal jetzt
habe ich zwei möglich was wir das bringt
aber gut sagt mir doch mal bescheint
table baum luca vor ihm an ich kann das
ja nicht riefen dann machen wir das noch
mal bei jugend mögest du beschritt so
was brauche ich noch ein extra table
sodann stimmen jetzt hier in table hin
und jetzt schauen wir mal ob das noch
funktioniert was ich denke
weil wenn das funktioniert jungs dann
haben wir endlich diamanten
das würde mich jetzt wo es funktioniert
und ich meine es ist im spiel drin von
da darf man es nutzen
da es funktioniert ich habe unendlich
diamanten die als schädlich luca läuft
bei uns bei uns klar zu sagen läuft bei
dir wir sind ja schließlich ein team
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt ganz egal
ist was ich gemacht habe ich mach das
jetzt einfach mal ich meine die
komplette stadt in der luft gesprengt
eben eben außer dem generellen er hat
wurde es für ihn jetzt voraus
das ist ein trick warte kommen das ist
ein glück aber ich meine steht nirgendwo
dass man das nicht darf magath war nicht
auch irgendwie sowas kommen so was mal
benutzt dafür ein bisschen lager
bekommen weiter für ärger bekommt also
nicht ärger bei der musterung alle
wieder zurückgeben aber komme ich mein
wieder passiert es sind jetzt noch
weiter denn gemacht ich weiß nicht also
hat auf jeden fall irgendwas mit
diamanten gemacht ich hab ich hab dich
fragen persönlich selber nicht gesehen
deshalb kann es nicht sagen alter dieser
scheiß regen ich habe acht fpsb nicht so
öffne ich bin so einfach nur noch in
gold
da komm ich kann es jetzt sich angucken
lukas lag zu setzen also ich mache jetzt
auf jeden fall erstmal glas für berg
habe also ich hoffe wie geht das
wie macht man das
doch im rafting rezept nein ich wollte
eigentlich gar keine glasfiber kamera
ich wollte mir diamond eyes machen
weißt du richtig gehört
was nämlich gar nichts verstanden weil
ich nicht gesagt habe ich bin richtig
crazy motherfucker bin ich heute hier
ich weiß nicht ob jemand als ich weiß
nicht ob das jetzt nicht vielleicht ein
bisschen zu viel war oder halt nicht
aber immer irgendwie alles schon mal
gemacht
passiert das anfang der anfang gewesen
ich habe drei stacks golden bleibt
deswegen habe ich das doch einfach von
ganz unten bis ganz oben zu mir ins haus
gelegt die braucht man ja auch sehr klar
die braucht man wirklich eigentlich 62
soll ab ende sondern habe ich ein medium
voltage ohne ray und ein lv transformer
brauche ich copper corp kupferkabel
kabel haben wir noch irgendwo poppea
poppea poppea haben wir nicht mehr
dann werden wir in skopje 90 koffer aus
new metal ich habe so viele junge mütter
irgendwie wie viel hast du denn ich habe
mich ist jetzt voll halbe diamond chef
von ungefähr junger mensch ich hab nur
660 halbe dorf fast das ist schon sehr
viel was ich halt haben weil sie man hat
halt erlaubt und so von daher ist es
okay
da kommt jetzt ein rein aus dem iran
mache ich mit jupiter gold gegen noch
mal dass ich was an den